yes small club
on october the 22nd donald trump and joe
biden will take the stage once again
lara with crowder will be live streaming
the event with costumes
big games and of course drinking game
you better be there too oh undercrowder
and i will be coming knocking at your
door
many men have come before now only two
remain
and when the dust settles when the
defeated rapey jim crow corpse is
dragged off the battlefield
i will be there to look the victor in
the eye
and i will utter only three words
keep america great
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
i don't know if this is fishing or if
this is what is this cranking somebody
in but i'm bringing you back in
no slurp we've been out of a rhythm oh
shoot oh
what the hell are you doing people we
were on the road doing change my mind
right two and a half hour town hall
the dueling town halls and so
everything's been off so i apologize but
i'm glad to be back with you
good morning mug club uh this morning
tuesday wednesday
and then the final debate on thursday
that's going to be uh quite a bit of fun
uh my half asian lawyer bill richmond is
here how are you hello good to be here
i'm glad to have you here quarterback
garrett hey what's going on audio wade
howdy
gerald how are you i'm well are you well
i'm very well still serving your
comments well done
yes little inside
joke there so we're gonna be talking
about quite a bit the polls the secret
trump voters today
um joe biden we just was just skimmed
over
from the media that he supports children
not only
supports he will change the law for
children transitioning
i don't know what uh and we will also be
talking of course about hunter biden
and the new laptop and uh perhaps uh
child pornography on there i don't know
who knows listen that's what people have
said i would never say that's what
people are talking about
that's what they are talking about true
statements i heard the q anon
don't like pedophiles so i don't know
them but i
too do not support pedophiles
as well is that a conspiracy why don't
you tell me it is
well then i guess i hate pedophiles and
a conspiracy
uh but first before we get to all those
stories and your questions
uh here's the uh we'll just watch joe
biden jake dapper claiming that he's a
stutter
every time he comes on stage or they
turn to him i'm like joe can you get it
out let's get the words out joe you kind
of feel bad for him
how do you think it makes little kids
with stutters feel when they see
you make a comment like that
uh first and foremost i had no idea
that joe biden ever suffered from a
stutter i think what we see on stage
with joe biden jake
is very clearly a cognitive decline
that's what i'm referring to
it makes me uncomfortable you have you
are no absolutely
that's so amazing it's so amazing to me
that i can try and figure out
an answer a cognitive decline you're
trying to tell me that what i was
suggesting
was i think that you were mocking his
stutter yeah i think you were mocking
his stutter and i think you have
absolutely no standing to diagnose
somebody's cognitive decline
i would think that somebody in the trump
family would be more sensitive
to people who do not have medical
licenses
diagnosing politicians all right
let me be really clear about this uh joe
biden doesn't have a stutter okay
in fact it wasn't even googled until
2019. i want to be clear the only
mention of it was somewhere in 2013 like
hey fun fact he had it when he was a kid
and now he's claiming it no no listen
he doesn't have a stutter he didn't have
a stutter it was never even google it
was never even a defense until 2019
and he you want to know how you know he
just go watch his
his statements at the clarence thomas
hearings it's not the stutter
it's the being a shitheal that you have
a problem with but
very quickly very articulate
articulately for i mean articulately for
for illogical arguments
of course of course yeah right so here's
the thing also let's assume that he has
a stutter
when people say that joe biden has uh
has clearly some symptoms of cognitive
decline and there have been many medical
professionals who have said this
including people we've spoken with who
don't necessarily want to talk on air
because
they don't want to get an audit if joe
biden happens to win
um that is not our primary gripe with
joe bud
when you say that it's cognitive decline
you're not basing it on a stutter
we're basing it on the fact that he
makes no sense and and really our
primary is that he just
makes stuff up yeah that's not a stutter
i don't know
i don't know i mean i've watched the
cable guy i'm not entirely sure and
we've had john stossel on the show who
actually had
speech therapy and has talked about it
stutters don't just
don't just it doesn't stutter is not a
synonym for compulsive liar
it's a form of tourettes so let's just
go through some of the recent ones just
recently he came out in the town hall
and said that he had been
endorsed by the boilermakers right they
were furious
they were furious news to me and there's
no no we absolutely did not this because
they endorsed trump and they had
angry calls from their members saying
you endorsed the guy who said he would
ban fracking and then said he wouldn't
ban fracking which he also made up and
then said he would ban fossil fuels they
said no no
where'd you hear that from the vice
president himself
someone say a reliable source then just
recently he said he never i have four
hundred thousand dollars from talking
about taxes
more than i've ever made well won't be
more than you make annually but that's
also not true he made 11 million in 2017
him and his wife it seems like a pretty
good and by the way that's not including
the fact if you look at all the years
where he made close to 400 000
but his son was affected he effectively
he used his son was the way he would
hunter biden is a shell corporation
hunter vine is a pass-through
entity he's a shell son jesus
you have that you have a guy who just
made up when i remember when he was
running for election in
against barack obama i go on down to
amy's diner there was no
way steiner didn't exist it did not
exist he just
makes things up it's not because he goes
i wha
wha went down amy's dying i don't know
it's not that it's that amy's diner is
not a thing
oh creepy joe well it all goes back to
his fitness to be able to do the job as
president of the united states and it's
obvious i can't believe jake tapper
responded like that he'd be like hey
just be nice he is
having some cognitive decline but just
you know act like he's your uncle and be
nice to him
he doesn't he could do that and then it
would lay me up if i run jake tapper to
not be nice i would say oh
be nice you idiot no jake
since when do we have to be nice with it
no i'm not saying you have to but i'm
saying
he could at least have said that because
she wasn't saying anything about
stuttering she was just saying he can't
put a sentence together no and it's a
lot and i'll tell you what this is
something i don't even want to spend
much time on this but
i was in my car and i have all of it
like i said i always have conservative
and liberal conservative and liberal so
i have a fox news news update and my
radio sort of podcast set up then i have
nvr
then i have something you know i have
conservative then i have abc news
and abc news it was a radio update
anyone out there who listens to the abc
news radio updates let me know if you've
you heard this there's a position about
this yeah yeah
there's a breakthrough about this kid
i'm in the car i swear to you this
happened yesterday
i'm in the car listening to my news
groupings
nice grouping and uh i hear
abc news covering this famous stutterer
on tick tock
and the kids like stutter doesn't have
to
define you and it's not something that
needs to be
fixed and it's this whole like two
minute segment on a on a tick tock
stutterer and i thought
well that was weird yeah looks like a
human interference
now i know exactly why wait a minute it
coordinates exactly yeah
the victim du jour is stutterers and by
the way of course
of course i have sympathy for people i
had a little bit of a stutter yeah
but i knew one of my best friends had a
severe got over it john stossel
got over it now we're telling people
it's not something to fix well it is if
you want to communicate with people who
don't want to be exhausted by a stutter
and by the way joe biden
never stuttered publicly until recently
it was never defense used until recently
i don't buy it and keep in mind that
these are the recent lies but this is a
guy who's been running for president
since tales of the crypt was in
syndication
in 1988 he had to drop out after getting
busted for blatant plagiarism
and lying completely again fabricating
an academic record that again
did not exist here you go there is one
less candidate in the race for the
presidency tonight
delaware senator joseph biden dropped
out of the hunt today
saying the disclosures about his
plagiarism in law school
and his exaggerations about his academic
record made it impossible
for him to continue impossible huh i do
it with incredible reluctance
and it makes me angry i'm angry with
myself
i'm always angry for having been put in
the position put myself in the position
of having to make this choice did you
put yourself in that position i'm sorry
it's just such both yes it is
until he's disserviced to the stuttering
community which i can't even really have
to say that now
exactly that's actually the point i was
gonna make if you're a professional who
works in this space if you're working
with children who actually have
stuttering or adults that
have a stuttering issue you're going
apoplectic
at someone who has not i mean let's not
say he didn't have it as a kid maybe he
did have his video right and that's
but not now you know 75 000 years after
his childhood to be saying
well now i have a stutter and that's
what causes me to develop right i have
to screen
and threaten people and call them dog
face pony soldiers like
yeah anything that terrifying joe's not
saying this
i don't this didn't come from joe
biden's camp right this came from the
media
saying well joe biden has had a stutter
and that's what you're making well then
they asked him just like they fed him no
i know but this
is
that's why you say stupid stuff right
right yeah
and why i sniff kids okay that doesn't
go that far yeah
i don't know can't help it i don't know
what is that cognitive decline or is
that
i think that's a mess either way
someone's got to notify their neighbors
so it's the law uh hey by the way we're
going to be moving my question to you
today
we're going to be going through i want
to showcase for you today we'll get to
this in a
second after we hit some breaking news
on hunter biden the electoral map people
saying do you think that donald trump
can win do you think that
anyone who tells you that this is not
that this is anything but
anyone's game at this point i want to be
clear i wasn't very clear anyone can win
yeah everyone can win at this point and
anyone who tells you differently
uh should be immediately discounted for
the same reasons that anyone who tells
you donald trump has a deadlock or joe
biden call it it's over
should be discounted this is an election
that can go either way
and i will say the prospects actually
look pretty good and i'm going to go
through i'm not a political wonk i
figure if charles krauthammer got it
wrong half the time probably one of the
most brilliant political minds of our
modern era
i am just this is just a swing and it
could be a mess
but uh so my question to you though is
do you still think that there's a secret
trump voter and how much of an impact do
you think that will have
i would argue more this election than uh
the previous election and
i'll get to that in a little bit but
first of course please do follow me on
the instagram
because uh that's where we do like weird
lifestyle stuff it's mostly pictures and
weird dogs lifestyle stuff
yeah and me and uh me doing i'm training
for my mr olympia
oh yeah yeah that's exciting i'm
training for mr natural olympia
oh so the lesser olympia but i cheat
with drugs
like okay it's mr natural yes and then i
sell you supplements that i never use
uh and we'll be taking your live chat of
course if you uh do consider joining
bloodshot.com club um we do an extra
full like 45 minutes of the show
behind the pay ball today we have manny
the art critic and we'll be talking
about joe biden and transgender kids
uh 69 annually for students veterans
active military and we'll be taking your
chat really quickly before we move on
let's see what this guy on cnn has to
say
it's like roger stone after a sauna
afternoon
well i hope so uh and obviously it will
depend upon whether we can come to an
agreement and uh
that will depend upon whether or not any
horror where give them
whether we can get mass
1.8 trillion that's all you get nancy
all right
boy um open the economy we'll go uh to
the debate thing
in a little bit first let's go to hunter
biden uh this is breaking
uh right now i don't want to say
necessarily broke yesterday if i'm not
mistaken i think so yeah
and that happened over the course of the
weekend so hunter biden of course we've
talked about his laptop and this is
something that the media has tried to
bury
uh and by media it's also important to
note that media and big tech are one of
the same right now
oh yeah this is we thought that they
were we were going to be at a point in
time
where the advantage of the internet is
was also the same
sort of uh the same drawback and that's
the the bathroom wall of society anyone
can speak
but we thought the plus in that sort of
uh scenario was that anyone can speak
and so people can
bypass the sort of gatekeepers and that
was the case for a long time that's
where we grew at record speed here with
this channel and you see
shows like joe rogan and independent
content how many independent content
creators have you seen
rise up through the ranks in the last
two years very few
because now big tech is trying to favor
and uh and trying to of course get
themselves some of those dollar dollar
bills from the big legacy media
companies
yeah and that's that's we're running
into now we used to have abcmccbs then
you had it sort of fractured because you
had cable and satellite
right and then viewership was really low
and now you have twitter facebook
youtube google that's basically the new
three networks only far more powerful
and they want the dollars that come from
the legacy media companies and so it's
very hard for people like us to compete
and so they can just say ah you know
what we're going to make sure that you
don't read the hunter by new york post
story
well why well because it wasn't verified
what about the trump calling military
losers and suckers
run it four years of russia being
processed
being prostituted yeah it sounds funny
on both sides yeah what about the good
people on both sides well yeah we'll run
it hold on a second did you watch 30
seconds on the other side of that clip
where donald trump condemned white
supremacy totally
we don't think it's misleading says our
fact checking group well who are they
they're independent but can we know who
they are
no they have shaped heads have you heard
about russia's
four dollars in misinformation campaigns
oh yeah yeah that should be on top of my
list um
so here's something now a new
development is that um
hunter biden's laptop and i'll also
provide some information here that
confirms that this is a real story this
is the most confirmed corroborated story
that we have
really heard in recent memory this is
important to note certainly more than
peeing prostitutes and anything in
russiagate
certainly more than uh the the recent uh
donald trump
i mean oh my god the recent suckers and
losers was the worst one to me
there's so many false alarms more than
the kavanaugh rape allegations
absolutely more by far are rape
allegations even more than the joe biden
rape allegations and there's a lot there
yeah
so uh
laptop was subpoenaed this broke here uh
by this lady at fox news
she kind of looks like she kind of has
like a an attractive lizard look but in
an attractive way ah
that's jade you are attracted to
elizabeth no i'm just saying like if a
beard
if they were like a disney bearded
dragon that were like the pretty girl at
love interest
she would look like this like an extra
character in kung fu panda is what
you're saying
yes oh wow so the biden laptop was
subpoenaed apparently now this i have
not fully confirmed but it does seem to
be accurate uh
by an fbi agent who generally works
whose main area of of specificity
is child pornography that's the person
who's handling the content of the
laptops here you go is where it broke
was the fbi agent who served the
subpoena
uh investigating child pornography
senator well
you just read the news report i i can't
comment any further i don't want to
speculate other than to say
that what i said publicly before our
report
uncovered so many troubling connections
so many things that need to be
investigated that i really think
we're just scratching the surface and
yes i've heard all kinds of things
that i think will probably be revealed
over the next few days
the apple doesn't fall too far from the
sniffing tree
um you know it's always like you want
your kid to stand on your shoulders
and go further than you did not with
children
misinterpreted that one biden family um
stick with fat biker chicks so this is
also something that
is not surprising to me because if you
had watched and we'll have a link in the
description below
you know uh mayor giuliani was on the
show when we did the stream
on thursday and just happened to drop an
exclusive into our lap
uh that we didn't necessarily expect
where he had not talked about this
anymore before our show
where he talked about how the lawyer had
actually
reached out to the computer repair shop
asking for it to be returned
how do you know that do you have any
proof of that he said yeah yeah this is
the dumbest
dumbest guy in law school and he also
said there's some things on this hard
drive at that point
some things that are funny and some
things that are not so funny now sitting
there going we're already talking about
him doing crack
and sex tapes i'm like so what pretty
people could be working
i will say that behind the scenes i have
heard some there's been alluding to this
i cannot confirm that but for those who
missed the interview here's the
bombshell that rudy giuliani dropped on
our show the comedy i was like
what do i do with this potato i get it
to the news
in fact i'll give you something that
really verifies it
the very morning this came out within
about 20 minutes
hunter biden's lawyer called the
merchant
and asked him if he could have the hard
drive back really
yeah well that's uh yeah that also
reminds me i need to call geek squad
we have the email evidence of that wow
wow that is the lawyer who's asking for
the hard drive back
that's almost as though it makes it
worse on them
[Applause]
dumbest thing a lawyer can do that would
you advise your job
with the dumbest
but he's a nice guy he cheated his way
through
but he's a nice guy by the way i don't
buy that at all joe biden is not a nice
guy when you look
again with clarence thomas when you look
at what he does it's a character
assassination
the fact that he called a man fat which
i've never actually heard as a
name hey listen here fat
whoa if i were the fat guy i'd like what
oh assume this one was a last name like
asian did you mean fatty
fat ass fat dumb ass like what i'm
usually
gonna call me fat that doesn't even
sting you sir
are the embodiment of fat doesn't make
any sense
like yes here's the problem is he just
he just doesn't understand how to split
the difference joe biden
it's like either fat or dog-faced pony
soldier where he's trying to
you don't know where he's gonna go fat
face dumb ass i'd be like oh i do a
little bit of a liv shriver puffy face
that hurts
but when you say fat it doesn't apply to
me and then
dog face ponies show it's nonsensical so
just say like ah
hey you coward okay fine like
yeah you you know you you fat faced
cowardly soldier okay fine
you you deserter like oh that's fighting
words but just
hey fat or dog fake pony soldier
let's split the difference somewhere in
the middle and by the way
if you really want to make someone's you
want to make it sting yeah
if you're going to insult someone as fat
you don't pick the fattest guy in the
room because he already knows he's fat
you pick someone who's like dad bod
maybe put on 30 pounds
what i mean because that will eat away
i'm right here
diabolical or rather gerald's right here
stephen no i'm the same white i'm good
no you know what i did love that time
when he was in the factory and he had
all the workers around him yeah there's
like
90 union guys all around him and he
tells the one guy he starts insulting
him yeah
i think he was a question about maybe
ar-15s or something like that yeah and
he just starts insulting and you're like
oh man okay this is the candidate for
president
for the democratic party a guy who's so
stupid as to his surroundings that he
starts insulting a union guy
basically and then he goes out and goes
ah don't worry they endorse me the guy's
like no
no
he referred to me as fat not an ejective
just a noun he thinks my name is fat and
he thinks he's dog-faced pony soldier
you lipid
hey you oxidized ldl
oh wow deep cut hey you
bad hdl two triglyceride ratio
it's hard to get that one out fast
enough couldn't get it to two to one you
son of a [ __ ]
devastated and every time he uses that
one i'm like and this is this is the
articulation of a stutterer
yeah like nine syllable insults here i
just wish there could be a schoolyard
brawl between him and donald trump as
far as insults without it being
broadcast
because that would just devastate joe
yeah
orange oh really is that the best you
got to stuttering joe is that what we're
going to blame your stupid insults on
also your filthy ugly way
oh what low blow
that's a low blow hey hey don't be don't
be jealous everyone wishes they could
have a wife who made 16 million dollars
from one year to the next year
oh no that's a big pay raise what
happened to my chair that is a
big pay raise did you break your chair
as well yeah
oh my gosh i love it can nothing be
sacred nothing at all we don't need
anything safe in my chair
well did what did it affect you oh there
we go
i was reaching on the wrong side oh my
gosh i forgot right from left
we were just making mistakes all right
sorry sorry we're getting off the rails
so uh what giuliani said there on the
show where he said yeah the lawyer
reached out yeah said the lawyer read
the the lawyer reached that the dumbest
guy in law school right
yeah uh so he probably has grenade like
he's a dog face ass face is what it's
called
he's got what do you mean by that
ridgeline well he's got a face that
resembles an ass so i call him ass face
stephen oh it's easy to remember thank
you uh
this has been confirmed after that was
breaking on our show with an email made
public from the lawyer i think is known
as george missions
george mazers george mesure the point is
it's been confirmed that the lawyer
reached out to the computer repair shop
like hey
can we have that back why my computer
back
why would you do that that is very
totally
yeah the fake computer they're totally
fake i heard through the grapevine that
the computer
uh that may or may not include child
pornography
has now been handed over to the fbi
agent who i
whom i know very well specializes in
child pornography
um is there any way you could give that
child pornography hard drive
back
is that maybe in the cards no no no it's
probably not should have expected more
from a dog face
pony compare computer repair man
talking about and i don't know you have
to talk to the president's lawyer
then there was a ukrainian lawmaker uh
andre
dirkcock i could be pronouncing that
gerkatch i don't know i could be
pronouncing it wrong i don't care
uh claimed a second uh biden laptop was
seized in the ukraine and is
containing evidence of corruption and
steve bannon who of course works at uh
at breitbart.com so that this is just
going to be a slow drip that they have
more to
release and that was the old andrew
breitbart playbook
was release something to allow the media
to claim that it's a false story that's
exactly what happened with anthony
weiner a lot of people forget this about
anthony weiner
andrew breitbart had the pictures he
told the media that he had the pictures
he
made sure that the media was able to
verify that the pictures were accurate
but because he didn't want to release
the
the pictures of anthony weiner because
he didn't want to destroy his family's
life
in the life of anthony weiner's children
it gave the median out where they
claimed andrew breitbart is making this
up and lying only when andrew breitbart
actually
took over the podium at anthony weiner's
press conference where he was going to
blame
andrew for a false story when andrew
went out and said
i have these pictures i didn't release
them because i don't want to destroy the
family anthony went out and apologized
so that is the andrew breitbart playbook
that a lot of people don't know
the media has been either ignoring it
they've had big tech who've been
ignoring it
and uh if there's something else that
comes out and confirms it and more
importantly that the media
knew it was confirmed that opens up a
whole
bunch of legal liability i've got to
imagine for all companies involved
if it can be proven that they knew which
was the case with anthony leader well
and the only thing that they're saying
right now is this is all russian
propaganda that this isn't something
that is even worth being printed
anywhere that there's no facts
behind like everything that i see the
media saying is getting parroted by
people on twitter oh this is just
russian disinformation it's like we just
can't whitewash every piece of
information you don't like as
russian but let's say that a russian
happened to give giuliani the actual
hard drive as opposed to the local geeks
right yeah
so well if you're right make it any less
relevant if the fact
is that hunter biden and joe biden have
been engaged in corruption after
corruption
listen if someone with the last name
that ends in vich
what sent this and it happens to include
child pornography
aren't you glad if that there's
accountability and maybe one
one more pedophile behind bars like this
is one of those things and there is no
evidence that that is the case no
because they've tried to make it seem as
though anyone who may even have at some
point been
russian if they've provided any
information uh that this is somehow a
russian disinformation campaign the
disinformation campaign
is twitter facebook throttling this
story
completely yeah but they've also
conditioned people to every time
something comes out that could be
damning they've conditioned them to hear
russian and election meddling and think
oh this isn't true i don't need to i
don't even need to take a look at this
even though the fourth largest
publication
newspaper in the united states ran with
us this is not some right-wing lunatic
way out on the fringes in his mom's
basement tweeting this story out this is
a newspaper then it was the judicial
oversight committee that got blocked
then it was the press secretary that got
blocked by
big media like how is there any doubt
anymore that they are
absolutely in the bag for joe biden
there's no doubt there's no doubt
there's a real problem any doubt one of
the one of the largest questions here is
if you have an entire
summer an entire uh presidency that has
been marred by having news outlets
claim their partisanship not just talk
about partisan
facts not just talk about facts which
really shouldn't be partisan again right
infusing opinion onto the facts and
twisting them and spinning them in a
certain way
which has now become the really the like
joe biden as a stutter or just making
them up entirely right
but even you know the new york times i
mean other places that should have
and a lot of their folks are trying to
tell the truth are not able to tell the
truth they're getting the spin
and now you come out and you're like
you're the ones that are saying oh this
is just russian disinformation
but it's so untrue that we're not even
gonna let anyone
see it not let anyone investigate it
right we're just gonna go ahead
rely on our immunity and just strip it
from the public record yeah
yeah it's really concerning yeah and
it's not like facebook and twitter and
google all of a sudden grew a conscience
and decided to start
you know censoring information that was
false with all of the things we've seen
with russiagate just with trump
and then with kavanaugh there is you
cannot be on the other side right now
and say well they're just making sure
that the bad information doesn't get out
they want to make sure that the stories
are true it's like
really a lady who couldn't remember
where when how anything but she thinks
it might have happened and
you ran with that zuckerberg grows a
conscience when he can grow a mustache
you mean when a cell's regenerated like
a real human being
becomes self-aware i'm sorry when he
blinks during seven hours of
congressional testimony
that is the wimpiest super computer ever
send him back to the future
we don't need him here hey the devil the
devil's biggest trick wasn't
you remember being around it's
convincing us that he wasn't mark
zuckerberg
that's that old phrase that's a good
trick uh i should have anyway let us
know what you think about it we'll be
following the story as it develops i'm
curious to see
what uh moore develops from this story
uh which by the way speaking of tech we
have a new sponsor here on this show
uh even brennan you should come in so a
lot of people don't know this um
many of you have had car insurance or
homeowner's insurance okay and probably
for a very long time it's one of those
things you probably checked for your
price right your homeowner's insurance
car insurance checked for the best price
a while back
and then said okay i'm all set but your
prices can creep up on you really and i
even realized after the sponsor came in
gabby that uh
i probably should have checked them oh
wow so i actually did check mine
because i got to take it recently
because i speed sometimes
way before in the past outside schedule
right
but not currently but
i literally checked it after that and i
it was a great experience and also the
other best part is is they stick it to
big tech all day long so
right and they also don't uh they also
don't release any of your private
information so
what gabby is sorry i should tell you
exactly what it is even brennan is
showing that that's the logo there and
you can go to gabby.com
crowder gabby.com you can just go and
check actually what your current
insurance rate is that you're paying and
gabby is a site that lets you
see what other prices you might have
available to you based on what you're
actually paying right now
what you're at what your current driving
level and record is like
i'm distracted brandon when was the last
you look like the liberty belt when was
the last time you got a haircut
one year ago one year wow how do you
know one year ago is there something in
your mind that dates it
no no it's just it's gross it gets it
cut every year on the same day
he looks like a like an unshorn alpaca
like just the hair
down in his house he looks like a like a
hipster
little lord fontelroy i'm pretty
confident you should not answer the
question i'm partially blind due to my
bangs when filling up
like a coffee shop long shanks this war
starts this is gonna be my hour
since going to be your out but anyway
you know what else can get disgusting
like brendan's hair
is your insurance rates that's true your
car insurance rates or your home
insurance rates so gabby uh you can go
and get your free check right now to
find out what your rates are that's
gabby.com
crowder uh it saves customers like eight
hundred dollars on average
nice 800 on average gabby.com crowder
and none of your info is sold
it's free to try elsewhere free to try i
want to see if it would stick in here
okay i think when bill
goes on there he puts asian and the
prices go up like three times but if he
takes it off
he just he leaves that part out i put
multiracial and they just say no we're
not even
we didn't accept that yeah i don't trust
which multiracial that means
well i have a family member who lives in
glendale and that's the highest car
insurance
uh in the in the country apparently all
the armenians which i never it's not
even a stereotype
armenians oh are bad drivers apparently
i have no idea why
yeah i thought it was i thought it was
because it was in close proximity to
koreatown turns out it's armenian
they're big butts the koreans they don't
it's just i think it's just someone
getting them back
for system of a down
you should have them dude they should
have them do a gabby commercial oh
the toxicity of your reigns of your
[Laughter]
no premiums
somewhere between progressive and
their lyrics do sound like libraries
they're just crazy words
gabby.com
[Laughter]
just despite you i listen to them every
morning on the way
it's a routine oh okay
uh all right let's move on here to the
electoral map
um a lot of people have been asking i
want to know again the question is what
do you think about the secret trump
voter you guys all bet on thursday said
if you have to bet
you still bet donald trump wins slightly
yeah but it's i i agree with you that
really anyone who says that they're for
sure now whether you're nate silver
or you're that homeless guy over at the
racetrack nobody really knows the answer
wait do you mean racetrack the gas
station because it sucks we only talk
you meant qt right that's why i
mentioned how bad it was
there are a lot of guys just roaming
around and they pee in your cup and then
racetrack puts it back like it's a new
cup
oh wow unverified
711 just takes the cup and goes floor
i don't know what 7-eleven is thinking
like
i've got i've gone every 7-eleven i've
gone to i go have you been to quick trip
your bathroom looks like lock it looks
like an episode of lock-up
it's 7-eleven oh my god i almost think
that 7-eleven it's an aesthetic because
i'm fairly certain every 7-eleven
bathroom has the exact same stains
all on the wall it comes pre-stained so
you don't see
all the papers i got to make sure we
have the dna spots
yeah and every single one it's like call
gerald a for a good time it's the same
number every time
i mean maybe i put that there and i call
and i never have a good time never never
good times not happy you think donald
trump wins i do think he
yes sorry that was the transaction nice
job
he wins because of quick trip okay so
here's some let me give you
uh my reasoning here as to why i think
uh it's very possible that donald trump
can
i think it's very possible that donald
trump could lose by a landslide and he
could win by a significant margin
all scenarios are possible however the
polls want to give you one side of the
story right now
uh where only one scenario is possible
and that's joe biden winning by
significant margin though that margin is
shrinking as we go into election time
also i should note i haven't been able
to do all the fact checking on this yet
but there are some polls that were
included in 2016 as part of the rcp
rolling average that are not included
this go around and have no idea
why keep that up so that is important to
keep in mind in mind that
biden's lead uh is more significant than
hillary clinton's
okay but as margin in many the margins
in many swing states
are actually lower right again all of
those margins are
generally shrinking this was i think
taken from this this weekend
um by the time you're watching this what
are we october this was taken from
october 17th i believe so if someone
goes oh you're like
just go to rcp and just click time
machine there's a date stamp on the ship
okay so looking at those margins that
you see all those toss-up states right
with the rcp averages
um this is how they have the map looking
effectively the electoral college map
uh just those are the states that are
not filled in they have biden with 216
and donald trump with 125 which at first
glance you're like oh my gosh okay that
looks pretty bad
jeremy does so again and again i could
be wrong about this i'm no
nate silver i'm not even i'm not even
nate bronze
but neither is nate silver you're better
than that nate silver has been
[Laughter]
using a simple formula i love how half
of asian bill show him he just had to
cough into his thing
no one cares if you all assumed that you
had kovitz you started
exactly i mean still though guys i
brought it to this country as a gift
oh yes the gift that keeps on giving and
now you all have it because
this morning that was my trick i had you
all taste the marshmallow rockstar just
to see how
dusting it was and i just licked the rim
i submitted my pink slip immediately
after i had to drink that
that was so bad marshmallow energy drink
it's like putting
drain cleaner in your stomach that
tastes worse than drain cleaner
um all right so i want to fill out the
map here
using a pretty simple formula because a
lot of people say well
how do we take into account the secret
trump voter okay again taking into
consideration that the swing state
margins
are significantly lower than hillary
clinton okay i'll only give
president trump when filling out this
map i'll only give him the states that
either a
uh he in which he outperformed his poll
significantly or b
won by a very wide margin meaning either
double digits or close to double digits
okay
so um for example let me kind of go
through this
michigan this is a story and this is a
perfect example of how the media can
kind of take facts
and present them selectively which they
do less and less because they just make
up facts
like joe biden that joe biden has a
stutter uh it's not even known that he
has a stutter and it certainly isn't
even known that it was widely known
because
you wouldn't have had to say it yeah
so uh michigan everyone talks about how
uh popular biden is and how
trump only won michigan by 0.5 like by a
half a percentage point okay and and
that is true
donald trump only won michigan i have to
say when you remember on election night
i was as shocked as anybody
you didn't think was going to happen i
didn't think he was going to win
michigan but here's the thing that's
important that the media isn't telling
you
the final polls had hillary clinton up
over 11
11.6 and trump won by between 0.3.5
wow um so that's a big deal when you
look at biden he's only up by what is he
up by six point something in michigan
right yeah six point seven
he's up by 6.7 michigan they had hillary
clinton up by 11
so if you actually look at that he
outperformed the polling
the polling average not one individual
poll the polling average in all of
michigan by a full
12 12
points think about when they talk about
margin of error it's usually two or
three percent
donald trump outperformed in michigan
when compared to hillary clinton
by 12 percentage points to get that half
wow
if he were to outperform biden by 12
percentage points he would win it by
seven percent yeah it would be a
landslide so this is why i say the key
does come if this secret trump voter is
still a thing he could very easily
overtake biden michigan
especially since again the trend is
recent polling has biden by
significantly less let's look at
wisconsin that's another example i was
very surprised with wisconsin
trump only won by 0.7 percent okay
understand
i understand that's not a lot but they
had clinton up
going into the election by seven percent
in 2016
by seven percent that means that donald
trump outperformed those polls
by eight percent so this is one thing
when people say actually the polls had
relatively right because hillary clinton
did win the popular vote they didn't
even have it close to
right in the swing states so wrong that
states that even consider swing states
all of a sudden became trump states
michigan wasn't considered a swing state
wisconsin wasn't considered a swing
state none of the pickup trump states
because no
one thought well he is how could he
listen there's no margin of
if a poll has a margin of error of plus
or minus 12 to 15 and there's almost no
value in a [ __ ] poll
but that is what happened yeah that is
what that is what happened
you sons of [ __ ] and just plain
[ __ ] i'm sorry
this is important the polls have become
a means to manipulate public opinion
and it is true the polls were generally
right and this is what frustration when
you see conservatives say this
who i agree with on a whole lot say well
actually the polls were pretty right
no they were not at all close in the
swing states and we covered we were one
of the few shows that covered that
election live stream
all night and we were very surprised um
then we look at uh again
so wisconsin biden's only up by 6.3
percent
so it's not a sure win that's not what
i'm saying no but i'm saying based on
the polling accuracy that you've seen
seen in the states it's certainly within
the margin of error and then i'm going
to apply another formula
here a couple of different possibilities
but first please do hit the notification
bell if you're subscribed on youtube
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot
the notification bell lets you know on
your mobile phone and
also if you don't want to hit it because
it burns hitting the click button or
maybe have an ipad
i just wiped a screen well then maybe
you shouldn't have eaten
fresh doughnuts yeah it's a bad plan
or shouldn't have gotten a touch screen
you poll taker so so can i say can i say
i think that the
i think that the secrets gorgeous tune
in mornings at uh 10 a.m eastern go
ahead
definitely tune in yes 10 a.m eastern um
i think that i think that the
secret trump voter is a real thing i
think there are definitely folks out
there who
will never put a sticker up a sign up
they won't even talk about it
and they are the type of person that is
still going to go out and vote because
they
are interested in the country and moving
it forward in a good way
right but i think perhaps a bigger
factor is going to be the lack of people
who are excited about joe biden there's
nothing exciting about joe biden you
haven't heard
a cogent cohesive plan from him you
definitely haven't heard it from kamala
and so ultimately you've got to get
excitement people have to be excited to
come out
people were not excited about hillary
but i think people are excited about
anti-trump so i don't
know if that's they are i think they're
going to have a lot of people turn out
and i think they will have a lot more
turn out but a lot of the folks who are
so
variantly anti-trump are the people who
aren't even going to show up they're the
people who are out there
holding their signs posting on facebook
yeah instagram
and then they just don't know it's
antifa and the bernie bros like they're
not going to vote for joe biden
and on election day you do have to fill
out a bubble next to somebody's name you
can't just vote against somebody there
that's not enough yeah no i think you're
right but i do think the secret trump
voter thing i mean
like you said they you know they're not
putting up signs because who can afford
that many signs unless you have
a clown car of trump signs it's gone the
next morning
i know because every single person i've
known or relative who put up a trump
sign it's up and it's gone
yeah exactly we put another one and it's
gone what is there is there the flash
i'm not even seeing anybody and the sign
is disappearing before my eyes
they have some sort of anti-trump magnet
it's like an acme magnet that just sucks
all the trump signs into one portion of
the earth they're gone immediately
people can't afford the trump signs
and people say well actually the polls
have recalibrated no no i look at the
polls not only do they
if they don't outright oversample
democrats they are
vastly oversampling independents like 26
30 something percent independence and
guess what
that's where your polling methodology
can lie
because you can easily have some
screening questions to make sure the
independents lean more left
and something that's really important to
keep in mind the secret trump voters
when people are asked hey who do you
think your neighbor is voting for
180 everyone thinks they're voting for
trump and every the majority of
americans
think that trump will win that's a
little crazy
that's the first time this has happened
when they go joe biden's ahead by double
digits in the bulls which is
factually inaccurate but that's what
they're claiming because cnn is only
saying like their own poll
yeah i like the fact that they're saying
that it gives trump voters and people
out there that are whipping votes in
these states like an opportunity hey get
out
it motivates them even more so keep
saying he's ahead i love it keep doing
it
so uh okay so let me give you a couple
different scenarios so using that
methodology where i'm only giving some
of those toss-up states to trump if he
won them by a wide margin
or outperformed his polls by a huge
margin
this is what that map looks like okay
now i want to be clear i'm not saying
that's what the election will look like
it's like a massacre
and see notice arizona isn't even in
there which is still a potential toss-up
so i'm actually playing that somewhat
conservatively using that methodology
but let me give you a more conservative
version okay
here's a more conservative version
because the polls were so inaccurate and
i want to
highlight the point here when anyone
tells you the polls were actually right
in the popular vote that's not the issue
the polls were
way off on the state vote so i am now
going to fill in the map
uh only moving the toss-ups to donald
trump
if he outperformed the polls by a
minimum of seven percentage points
here's what that map looks like so
that's only
seven points that's a lot that's way
outside the margin of error margin of
error is usually two and a half to three
percent
okay so here's another version okay
um if we go down the list and say all
right seven percent that's an extreme
version to make a point that
those are actually probably leaning
trump i feel pretty confident about that
map
where a lot of those may be leaning
trump yeah yeah now let's go down the
list and say okay
let's just take the states where donald
trump in 2016
outperformed the polls by a minimum a
minimum
of five percentage points and this is
exactly what that electoral map looks
like
and you get 277. and that's again
arizona's not filled in
nor georgia now i'm not saying that he's
gonna win wisconsin he's gonna win
michigan i'm not saying he's going to
win
uh pennsylvania uh i'm just saying that
there are a lot
of possibilities here yeah and if
someone tells you the polls were right
last time
they are wrong and they the polls were
not only wrong they were historically
wrong they were they were biblically
yeah it's like question
do you think that they got better
between the last four years
i don't know if they've gotten better
and i also don't know why certain polls
are being excluded
uh with the uh rrcp average right and
there's bias there's bias in polls like
you have to understand how scaling is
done and to see what kind of biases and
there are companies out there that are
pulling and trying to remove that bias
but i think
the landscape changed in 2016. yeah you
can't go back to polling the old way
they're like
well joe biden is is actually less ahead
nationally than hillary clinton was
almost
to the day this last week cnn was
reporting this over the weekend shocker
but they're like but don't worry he's
actually up in all of these other key
metrics and like everybody's just trying
to figure out
how do you judge accurately what people
would imagine like that
the stuttering community yeah they've
come out they love it full force
unfortunately their campaign stumping is
uh it's not on schedule yet
it's very long well there's two great
things
in our favor with this and i hate to say
it but one is that most of those voters
that are fired up to go out and vote for
joe biden are doing it by mail
that is a really bad way to go and vote
because historically
mail has been a horrible way to make
sure your vote is counted it ends up
getting lost it's not filled out
correctly so if you guys have
done your entire campaign is vote by
mail yeah you basically by the way we
have a running personality from our last
segment it's over two million votes that
are potentially compromised by mail two
million votes that have been legally
verified
uh are potentially compromised and i'm
not saying voter fraud but it includes
all the above fraud and compromise when
people say there's no evidence of mass
scale
voter fraud well actually there is
evidence of voter fraud to the tune
of tens of thousands absolutely if you
think that's for sure okay
fine then i get the hell out i don't say
that
like if you don't like if you don't like
donald trump leave america i'm saying if
you don't think that tens of thousands
of votes that have been verified
fraudulent
if you don't think that matters then you
don't really care about free and fair
elections and then
there are millions of votes that are
potentially compromised just because
do you okay dmv
yeah yeah yeah do you trust them
medicare medica do you really think that
you need to go on
yeah and handle elections yeah and if
joe biden loses then it's going to be
the democrats talking about how
unsafe mail-in voting is of course yeah
massive mail-in voting is just the dmv
with representatives
oh it's a nightmare it's just remote dmv
right i actually was going to say
nothing has made me more frustrated over
the last couple of weeks of hearing
uh folks lay at donald trump and the
gop's feet
this idea of no peaceful transition or
you know calling into question the
election itself when i i feel like i've
in the vast majority of that
i've actually heard from the left i mean
right and and you know we've made we've
made jokes and
they're i guess they're not even joking
they're true about questioning this you
made this point last week
about questioning it during the entirety
of the four years right the legitimacy
of the
of the president's term and i really do
think that you're going to see even more
strenuous
complaints arguments screaming from the
left
in the event that trump wins even on the
fourth itself we're going to see that by
the end of the day
because i think you're going to see all
these votes come in right and they're
going to go
no no no no no no no no wait till
january what was that
yeah really she wanted to repeat that
like i missed it i totally like the
warrior princess
[Laughter]
that's what they're going to do watch
out
look i mean i i know that this is going
to be close in some places but the the
polling is a great point that you
brought up the mail-in ballot thing is
going to be a huge issue but there's one
other thing in some of these swing
states that's really big
since march in florida the states that
let you register to vote by party and
let you declare which party you're for
there's been over a hundred thousand
more republicans
since march register in florida than
democrats new people registering
pennsylvania since
june over 77 000 more in north carolina
we've been talking about that's central
to their strategy to win by the way is
north carolina over 25 000 more
republicans registering to vote for the
first time
than democrats yeah just a year wow
right so that's a huge thing that we
haven't even faced
yeah but we haven't factored in the
stuttering campaign i i think there is
there is definitely a secret trump voter
but i think there are also people who
are
lying to the pollsters and then like
hanging out with bart simpson and just
laughing really every time
all of my old neighbors brag about how
they lie to the poultry
yeah i mean you know my one neighbor
who's like in his 90s
yeah i said i said well have you i said
i've never actually had one of these
poll takers call me have you he goes oh
yeah
that's really yeah so they must be
pulling people like you he goes yeah i
just lie
[Laughter]
he goes back to trimming his hedges wait
you lie yeah
so what do you mean i told him i'm about
inviting well nobody lies the other way
no yeah no nobody's going to be able to
try the other way
it's like please can someone shoot me in
the chest at point blank range because i
live in portland i mean
think about this for a second people
were voting trump kind of a roll of the
dice right a lot of people here
held their nose okay yeah we don't know
at that point but
you weren't being shot in the streets
for voting for donald trump that is
actually what is happening right now
and you wonder why people may be more
secretive and they're voting for trump
doesn't make any sense i'm not saying
he's going to win but i am saying that
it could go
either way and you certainly shouldn't
lose all hope and you shouldn't trust
all of the polls because that what is
that right that looks like a minion with
those goggles on
you're racist against people with
glasses aren't you we do
we have to get going we have to we have
manny the art critic and we're
talking about joe biden's position on
transitioning hormone replacement
therapy cutting off penises for children
so we know that this isn't necessarily
youtube friendly um and so
we do this out of respect for you
you you do piss off youtube